and we're just getting started
another big congratulations to Lawrence
Livermore National Lab their team
is here where are you team there you are
and they'll be yes
[Applause]
they'll be joining us uh after this for
a technical panel for those of you who
wish to stay to learn more
big Applause and thank you to the nnsa
the national nuclear Security
Administration
and everybody who has been involved in
this Fusion breakthrough that will go
down in the history books you're going
to hear more about the details of the
experiment from administrator Ruby and
director budil but first I'm going to
turn it over to the president's science
advisor and director of the ostp Dr
arati prabhakar
thank you so much
[Applause]
thanks secretary granholm what a
pleasure to be invited to come celebrate
this amazing moment here at the
department of energy it's really a
privilege to be here so when I heard
this news
for me the years fell away and all of a
sudden it was 1978.
I was a summer student
in the middle of my college Years 19
year old kid and I got the chance to go
work at Lawrence Livermore National
Laboratory and I showed up and so you
got a picture this I'm wearing my bell
bottoms I've got long black hair and I
show up and I'm a 19 year old kid and
they give me a laser to work on and I
said this is cool I like lasers but what
like what's this laser all about and
they said we think that if you point
enough lasers at a pallet of fuel we
want to see if we can get more energy
released from Fusion than the amount of
energy that the lasers deliver into that
pallet and I said well that's cool and I
spent three months working on this fund
laser and you know and after my
adventure with the laser that summer in
Livermore ended I went off and did
completely unrelated things but I have
always kept an eye out and watched to
see what was happening at Livermore as
they pursued this idea of ignition of
achieving this kind of controlled fusion
reaction for decades and um I I went off
and didn't do anything more about Fusion
but the people I worked with and their
successors kept going and they went
through periods of Triumph and they went
through tremendous struggles and
setbacks they never lost sight of this
goal and last week lo and behold indeed
they shot a bunch of lasers at a pallet
of fuel and more energy was released
from that Fusion ignition than than the
energy of the lasers going in and and I
just think this is such a tremendous
example of what perseverance really can
achieve and I had the great pleasure of
meeting the team whom you'll talk with
when you hear the panel in a little
while
and they have come from many different
parts of the world they've studied many
different fields many of them were
summer students that live or more
decades after I was so it took not just
one generation but generations of people
pursuing this goal and uh it's a
scientific Milestone scientific energy
Break Even to achieve this but of course
as with all of these kinds of complex
scientific undertakings it's also an
engineering Marvel beyond belief and and
this duality of advancing the research
building the complex Engineering Systems
both sides learning from each other this
is how we do really big hard things so
this is just a beautiful example
so um you know I also been reflecting on
how long the journey can be from knowing
to doing because it's a century since we
figured out that it was Fusion that was
going on in in our sun and all the other
stars and in that Century it took it
took so many different kinds of advances
that ultimately came together to the
point that we could replicate that
Fusion activity in this in this
controllable way in a laboratory uh and
and I think it's just a reminder that
sometimes even when we know something
it's a very long time before we can turn
it into something that we can actually
harness and start to be able to use and
as the secretary described I think it's
that that really that Prospect now is
one step closer in a really exciting way
okay so uh you know let me just finish
by saying I think this is an amazing
example of the power of America's
research and development Enterprise this
is what the department of energy works
every day to support and to drive it's
what our office of Science and
Technology policy at the White House
focuses on every day is how do we
strengthen and Advance this Enterprise
and it is an Enterprise that the
president President Biden has championed
in a way that no one really ever has
before he submitted the a budget for
supporting Federal r d that is the
biggest ever that we've had in this
country and so I want to take a moment
and congratulate the entire department
of energy with secretary granholm's
tremendous leadership the nuclear the
national nuclear Security Administration
here that has championed this effort for
so long Lawrence Livermore National
Laboratory and especially in
particularly all the scientists and
Engineers uh across many years who got
us to this moment
President Biden loves to say that the
one word that defines America is
possibilities and this is such a
wonderful example of a possibility
realized a scientific Milestone achieved
and erode ahead to the possibilities of
for clean energy and even deeper
understanding of the scientific
principles that are at play here so
thanks again congratulations and all the
best from the White House
and now thank you
thanks so much and now it's my privilege
to get to introduce Jill Ruby she is the
under secretary for nuclear security
here at the department of energy and
also the administrator of nnsa
[Applause]
well good morning
um thank you Dr brubakar for joining
nnsa to celebrate our incredible
achievement and thank you secretary
granholm for kicking us off and being
such a tremendous supporter of science
the success would not be possible
without with strong support for
foundational research by the U.S
government
and by the sustained investment in our
National Laboratories
Monday December 5th 2022 was an
important day in science
reaching ignition in a controlled Fusion
experiment is an achievement that has
come after more than 60 years of Global
Research development engineering and
experimentation
the people at Lawrence Livermore
National Laboratories National ignition
facility reached this ignition Milestone
because of the work others did before
them
their analysis of data and models their
continued pursuit to have the best
possible facility and their sheer
excellence and Grit
I would like to thank the members of
Congress thank you so much for being
here today that supported the national
ignition facility because your belief
and the promise of visionary science
has been critical for our mission
I'd also like to thank the international
partners that worked with us on this
because their collaboration demonstrates
the power and possibility of advancing
scientific Pursuits
but finally a giant thank you to The
Talented Federal defense programs and
National Security Enterprise teams that
supported this work at Lawrence
Livermore we are so proud of the
accomplishments of our livermore's
national ignition facility
the net
[Applause]
the national admission facility is the
world's largest and most energetic laser
system
during experiments
192 high energy lasers Converge on a
Target about the size of a peppercorn
heating the heating a capsule of
deuterium and tritium to over 3 million
degrees Celsius and briefly simulating
the conditions of a star
in achieving ignition the researchers at
Lawrence Livermore have opened a new
chapter
an nnsa science-based stockpile
stewardship program enabling us to study
new regimes along with this we have
taken the first tentative steps towards
a clean energy source that could
revolutionize the world
early this earlier this year I had the
opportunity to remember the 30th
anniversary of divider the last
explosives nuclear weapons test
conducted by the United States
and reflecting on divider I spoke of how
far our stockpile stewardship program
has come and in how many ways we Now
understand our nuclear weapons better
than we did when we were testing
unlocking ignition at nif
will allow us to probe the extreme
conditions found at the center of
nuclear explosions and address
significant long-standing stewardship
questions the unprecedented precedent
and nature of reaching ignition confirms
what I and previous administrators of
the nnsa have been saying for decades
there is no more dedicated or more
talented group of scientists in the
world as it should be
the tireless efforts of thousands of
people from around the National Security
Enterprise nuclear security Enterprise
and their predecessors are responsible
for this breakthrough
we honor their intelligence their
commitment and their determination
going forward we know we have we will
make further breakthroughs we'll have
further setbacks
but all of this is in the interest of
promoting National Security
pushing towards a clean energy future
and redefining redefining the boundaries
of what's possible
thank you for being here I'd like to
introduce Marv Adams the Deputy
Administrator for defense programs to
speak on this achievement
[Applause]
thank you administrator Ruby a
paraphrasal of Abraham Lincoln strikes
me as fitting here
the world will little note nor long
remember what we say here
but it can never forget what they did at
the national ignition facility
so let's recap a team at Lawrence
Livermore National Lab National ignition
facility made the following happen
there's a tiny cylinder here at the end
of this that you probably can't see it's
about so tall and this wide inside that
was a a small spherical capsule about
half the diameter of a BB
192 laser beams entered from the two
ends of the cylinder and struck the
inner wall they didn't strike the
capsule they struck the inner wall of
this cylinder
and deposited energy and that happened
in less time than it takes light to move
10 feet so it's kind of fast
x-rays from the wall impinged on the
spherical capsule
Fusion fuel in the capsule got squeezed
Fusion reactions started
this had all happened before a hundred
times before
but last week for the first time they
designed this experiment so that the
fusion fuel stayed hot enough dense
enough and round enough for long enough
that it ignited and it produced more
energies than the lasers had deposited
about two Mega joules in about three
Mega joules out a gain of 1.5
the energy production took less time
than it takes light to travel one inch
kind of fast
so this is pretty cool I have a special
message to listeners who want to work on
exciting challenging and important
problems we're hiring
foreign
[Applause]
Fusion is an essential process in modern
nuclear weapons and fusion also has the
potential for abundant clean energy as
you have heard and we'll hear more the
Breakthrough at nif does have
ramifications for clean energy
more immediately this achievement will
advance our national security in at
least three ways
first it will lead to laboratory
experiments that help nnsa defense
programs
continue to maintain confidence in our
deterrent without nuclear explosive
testing
second it underpins The credibility of
our deterrent
by demonstrating World leading expertise
in weapons weapons relevant Technologies
that is we know what we're doing
third continuing to assure our allies
that we know what we're doing and
continuing to avoid testing will advance
our non-proliferation goals also
increasing our national security
the achievement we celebrate today
illustrates that big important
accomplishments
often take longer and require more
effort than originally thought
and that these accomplishments are often
more than worth that time and effort
that they took
with that I would like to welcome my
friend and colleague Dr Kim Goodell
the director of Lawrence Livermore
National Laboratory to speak about her
Laboratories
secretary Dr pravacher administrator
Ruby and Deputy Administrator Adams
thank you for your remarks today and for
your support
this is a historic achievement for the
team at Livermore our collaborators and
Academia and labs in the U.S and abroad
our industry Partners the fusion
Community writ large and the many
supporters and stakeholders in the
National nuclear Security Administration
the department of energy and in Congress
who've ensured we could reach this
moment even when the going was tough
over the past 60 years thousands of
people have contributed to this endeavor
and it took real Vision to get us here
building the national ignition facility
was an enormous scientific and
engineering challenge I like Dr
prabhakar's emphasis on the importance
of bringing those two together
in the end after all that work the laser
has exceeded its performance goals
opened whole new areas of high energy
density science to exploration and
delivered the data we need to keep our
nuclear deterrent safe secure and
effective
our pursuit of fusion ignition over the
past decade at nif was an incredibly
ambitious technical goal many said it
was not possible
the laser wasn't energetic enough the
targets would never be precise enough
our modeling and simulation tools were
just not up to the task of this complex
physics
progress has taken time but last August
when we achieved an unrecord yield of
1.35 megajoules putting us at the
threshold of ignition many took notice
and last week our pre-shot predictions
improved by Machine learning and the
wealth of data we've collected indicated
that we had a better than 50 percent
chance of exceeding Target gain of one
60 years ago when John Knuckles and his
team proposed that lasers could be used
to produce Fusion ignition in the
laboratory it was beyond audacious
the laser had just been invented and was
far from the mature tool we know today
but this is really what National Labs
are for
tackling the most difficult scientific
challenges head on learning from the
inevitable setbacks and building toward
the next idea
Lawrence livermore's been at the center
of the ICF Community across these many
decades and ICF has been a centerpiece
of our lab
indeed people often say that llnl stands
for lasers lasers nothing but lasers
but I think our motto sums up our
approach nicely Science and Technology
on a mission
this achievement opens up new scientific
realms for us to explore and advances
our capabilities for our national
security missions
it demonstrates the power of U.S
leadership and Science and Technology
and shows what we're capable of as a
nation
and as the secretary mentioned
breakthroughs like this one have
generated tremendous excitement in the
fusion community and a great deal of
private sector investment infusion
energy
but this is only possible due to the
long-term commitment of public
investment in Fusion science
the Science and Technology challenges on
the path to Fusion Energy are daunting
but making the seemingly impossible
possible is when we're at our very best
ignition is a first step a truly
Monumental one that sets the stage for a
transformational decade in high energy
density science and fusion research and
I cannot wait to see where it takes us
thank you
foreign
back to secretary granholm great
we will open up for a few minutes of
questions and I think that our public
affairs team Chad is going to be uh
navigating that and of course we have
the experts
and just give your name and uh your
outlet please we're taking questions on
on this topic thank you
yeah hi thanks all right Nadder from
Bloomberg News I'm curious how long you
think it'll be until we see
commercialization of this technology and
also as a follow-up if this happened on
last Monday why are we just hearing
about it now thank you
um it's going to take a while before we
see this commercialized I don't know if
you want to say a word about that
sure
um yes there are uh very significant
hurdles not just in the science but in
technology this is one igniting capsule
one time and to realize commercial
Fusion Energy you have to do many things
you have to be able to produce many many
Fusion ignition events per minute and
you have to have a robust system of
drivers to enable that so you know
probably decades
uh not six decades I don't think I think
not five decades which is what we used
to say I think it's moving into the
foreground and probably you know with
concerted effort and investment a few
Decades of research on the underlying uh
Technologies uh could put us in a
position to build a power plant
on the question of what we've been doing
for the last week the team has been hard
at work analyzing data
it turns out that when you ignite one of
these capsules it's it's unambiguous
that something big happened
I make a lot of neutrons but the data is
not trivial to to analyze and the team
invited their all of their team members
who understand the individual
Diagnostics to come in and work together
to look at all the data to make sure we
had the numbers right and we brought in
an external team of experts to do a peer
review before we were ready to release
the numbers it's really important that
we tell you uh the facts and that we get
them right before we go public so that's
what we've been doing for a week
so
we should probably stay there
um two quick questions uh one um
I know this uh the the the the positive
uh net return is the important thing but
how much energy does it take that we
talk about the I guess the wall plug
energy how much wall plug energy did it
take and are there implications for
other types of fusion is this something
that could inform magnetic confinement
Fusion as well so the laser requires
about 300 megajoules of energy from the
wall to drive two megajoules of laser
energy which drove three megajoules of
fusion yield
our calculation suggests that it's
possible with a laser system at scale to
achieve hundreds of megajoules of yield
so there is a pathway to a Target that
produces enough yield but we're very
distant from that right now so 300
megajoules at the wall two megajoules in
the laser so this really is talking
about Target gain
greater than one
and then there was a second part to your
question but does it inform uh magnetic
Fusion yes so there are many common uh
things about plasma science and the
materials you need to work in Fusion
environments diagnostic techniques Etc
essentially magnetic Fusion uh works at
low pressures and densities and for long
times whereas inertial confinement
Fusion works at high pressures and
densities for very short times so there
are some similarities in the underlying
physics but the the fundamental concepts
are quite different
uh secretary grunt home Pete bear with
ene News Congress has charged you and
the department with making decisions
about the most promising to signs for a
pilot Fusion plant and you're in the
middle of that process now
um
how are you going to approach that and
what are your concerns about making
those kind of choices well clearly the
folks will be evaluating are the
Professionals in this who are the
scientists who do this work and they
will like they do with all of these
funding opportunity announcements do a
whole peer review process of each of the
applications to determine which ones are
most likely to be successful given given
the challenges there's no parameters on
whether this is these are magnetic
confinement plans or laser confinement
plants we are just looking at the best
proposals that come in and hopefully
we'll have a decision on that first 50
million at the you know early in the new
year
hey there secretary Gary grumbach from
NBC news here there's questions about
the ability to scale here and that was
touched on a little bit as it relates to
power plants Etc but can you talk about
the ability to scale and who should be
in charge of that scaling private
government bull well clearly we want the
private sector we need the private
sector to get in the game though it's
really important that there has been
this incredible amount of U.S public
dollars going into this breakthrough but
all of the steps that we'll take that
will be necessary to get this to
commercial level will still require
public research and private research we
know that there's been a huge interest
among the private funding Community
startups Etc and we encourage that the
president has a decadal vision to get to
a commercial
Fusion reactor within obviously 10 years
so we've got to get to work and this
this shows that it can be done which is
has been a question can you get there
this demonstrates it can be done that
threshold being crossed allows them to
start working on better lasers more
efficient lasers on better containment
uh capsules Etc the things that are
necessary to allow it to be modularized
and taken to commercial scale
thanks so much I just wanted to clarify
you're saying you know there's a goal to
get this in a decade you had said that
there would be decades plural in terms
of commercialization how do you
reconcile that was in what is the
timeline here I think I get that so
there's two approaches to commercial
Fusion Energy one is based on magnetic
Fusion using devices like tokamax one is
inertial Fusion there are private
companies pursuing both approaches
um the technology development the
foundational technology to begin to
scale up toward a power plant is further
along in the magnetic Fusion community
and it's building more directly off the
work that's been done in recent decades
at facilities like jet in the United
Kingdom at the Princeton plasma physics
Lab at MIT to build the foundational
Technologies up for magnetic Fusion
Energy
you know the national ignition facility
has been focused on creating this first
step if we could not ignite capsules in
the laboratory you could not see a
pathway to an inertial confinement
Fusion Energy plant so this was a
necessary first step
but the nif is built on foundationally
on 1980s Laser Technology so you know we
need to bring modern technology
approaches to the drivers we need to
think about all the systems questions
and now that we have a capsule that
ignites we need to figure out can we
make it simpler can we begin to make
this process easier and more repeatable
can we begin to do it more than one time
a day can we start working toward rep
rate and each of these is an incredible
scientific and engineering challenge for
us so while magnetic Fusion may be a
little bit in front having that
portfolio of approaches is really a
great place to be because they'll feed
these communities will feed off each
other we'll learn we'll continue to
advance the field and many technologies
will grow out of both fields in addition
to the path to a fusion power plant so
that you know I think having both is
really important
you'll hear in the panel about some of
the potential advantages of an inertial
confinement Fusion approach it's a
little bit different
so I think it really is important to
keep us on that pathway and with
investment with energy
no pun intended sorry about that
um
with real investment and real Focus you
know that time scale can move closer
we were in a position for a very long
time where it never got closer right
because we needed this First Fundamental
step so we're in a great position today
to begin understanding just what it will
take to make that next step and then
where that boundary is I'm guessing
because I don't want to give you a sense
that you know we're going to plug the
nif into the grid that's not that is
definitely not how this works
um but but this is the fundamental
building block of an inertial
confinement fusion power scheme
well
um congresswoman Lofgren joined us as
well thank you so much and there are a
number of uh lab you know due has 17
National Labs a number of those lab
directors are also populating this
audience as well I I know that Kim would
say this has been a group project and
would acknowledge uh the other labs that
have contributed to this effort as well
and are working on their Solutions so
thank you everybody so much and if you
hang around for a little for a few
minutes we're going to break here and
then set up for the technical panel for
those who wish to stay thank you